[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem Weihnachtsabend wir haben unter
anderem diese Themen für Sie
solidarisch gegen die Krise Deutschlands
Kirchen rufen in ihren
weihnachtsbotschaften zum Zusammenhalt
auf
Chaos an Weihnachten ein heftiger
Wintersturm mit extremer Kälte trifft
Millionen Menschen in den USA
und alle Jahre wieder über den Versuch
noch in letzter Minute ein Geschenk zu
ergattern
ein besonderer heiliger Abenteuer in
Zeiten des Krieges in Europa mit
Versorgungsproblemen und hohen Preisen
dieses Jahr hat vielen viel abverlangt
sagt der Bundespräsident in seiner
Weihnachtsansprache aber eines könne uns
niemand nehmen unsere Großherzigkeit im
Umgang miteinander die beiden großen
christlichen Kirchen Verurteilten heute
Krieg und Gewalt betonten aber zugleich
das Recht der Ukraine sich mit Waffen zu
verteidigen Jana Becker
Heiligabend in Bielefeld die
Ratsvorsitzende der Evangelischen Kirche
in Deutschland hebt in ihrer Predigt die
Bedeutsamkeit von Frieden und
Zusammenhalt hervor die
Weihnachtsbotschaft vom Frieden ist
Ihrer Meinung nach selten so nötig
gewesen wie in diesem Jahr
wenn Krieg auf Erden ist und Unfrieden
dann ist die Ehre Gottes angegriffen und
deshalb wird jeder Schritt der in
Richtung Frieden geht nicht vergeblich
sein heute wird die Kirche voll die
Menschen spüren die Gemeinschaft und wir
sind eine hoffnungsgemeinschaft als
Christen auch Georg betzing-vorsitzender
der Deutschen Bischofskonferenz erinnert
in seiner Weihnachtsbotschaft an den
Krieg gegen die Ukraine in der Kapelle
des Limburger bischofshauses appelliert
er an Solidarität und an den
Zusammenhalt in unserer Gesellschaft
wir leben in schwierigen Zeiten viele
sind belastet und das treibt uns
irgendwie auch auseinander davon hören
wir ja ständig und deshalb ist
Weihnachten als ein festes Zusammenhalts
so wichtig Familien kommen zusammen wir
treffen uns wir reden miteinander singen
und viele beten auch in den
Gottesdiensten und das macht uns stark
auch die Besucher der
heiligabendveranstaltung in der Kölner
Philharmonie schätzen an den
Weihnachtstagen besonders dass man
zusammenrückt dass man Gespräche für
tiefgründige Gespräche dass es einfach
ja vielleicht auch Familie
Freundschaften stärken die Familie dass
sie zusammenkommt und ich sag mal daraus
wieder neue Kraft schöpfe das nächste
Jahr
zunächst aber feiern heute Christen
weltweit die Geburt Jesu festlich und
besinnlich zugleich
Weihnachten hält Russland nicht davon ab
weiter die Ukraine zu bombardieren bei
Angriffen auf Herr Sonnen sterben nach
ukrainischen Angaben mindestens sieben
Menschen mehr als 50 wurden verletzt
Präsident selenski sagte das sei kein
Krieg sondern töten um einzuschüchtern
und aus Vergnügen die Stadt herson war
erst kürzlich von der Ukraine
zurückerobert worden der Großteil der
Region wird weiterhin von Russland
kontrolliert
immer wieder Luftalarm immer wieder
Raketen immer wieder tote und Zerstörung
schwer vorstellbar wie die Menschen in
der Ukraine das ertragen und trotzdem
weitermachen unsere reporterin Anne
Brühl war an einem Ort wo um jedes neue
Leben gekämpft wird
ein Kind ist geboren in hakiff mitten im
Krieg der kleine Lipp schleppt friedlich
im Arm seiner Mutter
Entschluss gefasst ein Notkaiserschnitt
zu machen alles verlief sehr gut dank
den Ärzten auf der Entbindung Station
normalerweise die schweren Fälle
maria ist gerade mal zwei Stunden alt
sie kam als Frühchen auf die Welt und
muss in den kommenden Tagen operiert
werden das ist gefährlich denn wegen der
russischen Angriffe fällt immer wieder
der Strom aus bis der Generator
anspringt es
10 15 Minuten sind kritisch denn die
Apparate funktionieren in dieser Zeit
nicht wir müssen die Kinder entweder
selbst per Hand beatmen oder brauchen
Personal das uns hilft wenn unsere Hände
alleine nicht reichen
die meisten Babys hier hatten einen
holprigen Start ins Leben dazu kommt der
Krieg die ungewisse Zukunft die alles
noch schwerer macht
die Eltern des kleinen Herr Lipp haben
vor allem einen Wunsch für ihre
neugeborenen Sohn in erster Linie möchte
ich Frieden für mein Kind und für alle
Kinder damit man Jungen nicht das erlebt
was die Kinder jetzt hier erleben
ihr Ehemann ist optimistischer
alles wird gut ich wünsche uns allen ein
friedlichen Himmel einen friedlichen
Himmel nichts können Sie an Weihnachten
im Kinderkrankenhaus von hakif besser
gebrauchen
mit Blick auf den Krieg in der Ukraine
ist die Botschaft von Weihnachten eine
Botschaft des Friedens heißt es heute
aus Bethlehem der Geburtsstadt von Jesus
Christus dort wurde das Weihnachtsfest
erstmals wieder richtig groß gefeiert
seit Beginn der corona-pandemie und so
kamen Christen aus aller Welt ins
Heilige Land Thomas Reichert berichtet
[Musik]
Weihnachten in Bethlehem beginnt mit
doodlesäcken ziemlich vielen davon gut
zwei Stunden lang ziehen sie in Richtung
Geburtskirche bewundert von
palästinensischen Christen und Muslimen
und Verwundeten englischen Touristen
die Vorstellung dass man nach Bethlehem
kommt in den Nahen Osten nach Palästina
und das dort Dutzende von Dudelsack
Kapellen spielen ist einfach bizarr und
wunderbar
es ist eine Tradition aus Zeiten als die
Briten hier das Sagen hatten auch die
Schülerinnen von St Josef pflegen sie in
den Tagen zuvor haben sie fleißig geübt
für diesen Auftritt Christinnen neben
Muslima
Weihnachten ein großes zusammenkommen
voller Liebe und Frieden mit unserer
Musik wollen wir den Menschen den Geist
von Weihnachten nahebringen ohne die
Spaltung zwischen Religionen oder
Geschlechtern
es ist eine Botschaft des Friedens die
auch der lateinische Patriarch bei
seinen Einzug nach Bethlehem mitbringt
tatsächlich aber war es ein Jahr voller
Gewalt fast 30 Tote auf israelischer
Seite bei Terroranschlägen mehr als 150
auf palästinensischer bekämpfen mit
Israels Armee
für mich ist diese Feier ein Zeichen der
großen Widerstandsfähigkeit des
palästinensischen Volkes und der großen
Bewunderung für die Tatsache das
Bethlehem wirklich die Stadt des
Friedens weltweit ist
mindestens sendet Bethlehem heute ein
Zeichen der Verständigung in eine Welt
die in diesem Jahr so wenig friedvoll
war
fragen wir Thomas Reichert in Bethlehem
wie erleben sie die Stimmung dort
also ich würde sagen die Stimmung ist
gespalten einerseits spüren wir viele
Leistungen werbe dass die
corona-resektion wächst und es sind zum
ersten mal wieder richtig viele Besucher
da es wird der Stadt gut den Geschäften
und den Hotels in Bethlehem findet man
heute abend schwer eine Herberge
vielleicht so wie damals auf der anderen
Seite spielt man auch viel Frustration
ja Verzweiflung Bethlehem fühlt sich
vergessen von der Welt gefangen in einem
Konflikt der Jahrzehnte alt ist zwischen
Israelis und palästinen sind ist der
Konflikt ist dem diesem Jahr noch
blutiger geworden und dann ist er ja
auch noch die neue israelische Regierung
und der Benjamin Natalia die in ihren
rein viele Anti arabische Nationalisten
hat also befürchten dass der Konflikt
noch blutiger werden könnte und insofern
ist die Weihnachtsbotschaft das
Bethlehem heute
nur beschränkt hoffnungsvoll und
friedlich danke für dieses Stimmungsbild
Thomas Reichert war das live aus
Bethlehem
nach Frankreich fremden Hass ist
offenbar das Motiv des tödlichen
Angriffs in einem kurdisch geprägten
Viertel in Paris der mutmaßliche Täter
ein 69-jähriger Franzose bezeichnet sich
nach Polizeiangaben selbst als Rassisten
seit gestern kommt es in der
französischen Hauptstadt immer wieder zu
Protesten und gewaltsamen
Auseinandersetzungen mit der Polizei bei
dem Angriff am Freitag hatte der Mann
drei Menschen erschossen und mehrere
verletzt
gerade erst haben die radikal
islamischen Taliban in Afghanistan
Studentinnen ein hochschulverbot erteilt
jetzt schränken Sie die Rechte von
Frauen weiter ein alle
Hilfsorganisationen wurden angewiesen
ihren MitarbeiterInnen zu verbieten zur
Arbeit zu kommen das Geld dafür in und
ausländische nicht
Regierungsorganisationen
ungemütlich bis extrem gefährlich ist es
an diesem Heiligabend in den USA 17
Menschen kamen bislang durch Sturmtief
Elliot ums Leben die meisten durch
Verkehrsunfälle
Wind Schnee und Eiseskälte haben weite
Teile des Landes fest im Griff vom
Norden und mittleren Westen hat sich der
Wintersturm inzwischen nach Osten und
Süden ausgebreitet mehrere Bundesstaaten
riefen den Notstand aus Lutten Linus
als hätte Wintersturm Elliot das Leben
zugedeckt und eingefroren bis 90
Stundenkilometer schnell raste durch
Buffalo im Bundesstaat New York und
bringt minus 40 Grad Kälte im dichten
Schnee und ohne Sicht bleiben selbst die
Helfer stecken
auch Feuerwerk Polizei und Rettungswagen
kommen nicht durch die Situation ist
schrecklich wegen des Blizzards endet
die Sicht häufig kurz hinter der
Windschutzscheibe
die Folge schwere Verkehrsunfälle und
hunderte Autofahrer die strandeten und
eine eiskalte Nacht verbringen mussten
wer es unbeschadet durch Sturm und
Schnee schaffte war heilfroh darüber
passieren im Moment du musst hellwach
sein
in der Nacht verlagerte sich der Sturm
immer mehr in den Osten der USA die
Behörden riefen dringend dazu auf zu
Hause zu bleiben
das hier ist lebensgefährlich schützt
euch schützt eure Familien tretet keine
Fahrten an bis die Straßen wieder frei
sind
auch das Flugzeug war oft keine
Alternative vor allem im Norden der USA
wie hier in Boston wurden tausende Flüge
gestrichen und weihnachtspläne
durcheinandergewirbelt unsere Flughafen
in South Dakota ist ganz geschlossen
worden wir mussten nach Nebraska und
hatten dann noch Verspätungen Washington
DC
hunderttausende Haushalte sind zur
Stunde noch ohne Strom und Millionen
US-Amerikaner stehen vor dem
vulkältesten Weihnachtsfest ihres Lebens
China kämpft derweil mit einer immer
größer werdenden corona-welle während
die amtlichen Zahlen das wahre Ausmaß
längst nicht mehr wiedergeben stoßen die
Kliniken an ihre Grenzen und müssen ihre
Kapazitäten erweitern experten rechnen
mit hunderttausenden von Toten nach fast
drei Jahren hatte China seine harte
null-kovit-politik Anfang des Monats
abrupt aufgehoben und das obwohl vor
allem unter den älteren viele nicht
ausreichend geimpft sind
jetzt zum Weihnachtsgeschenke Trubel da
gibt es ja ganz unterschiedliche Typen
die einen planen Monate voraus und haben
gefühlt schon im November alle Geschenke
die anderen spurten in letzter Minute
los als ob sie überrascht davon wären
das Weihnachten diesmal am 24 Dezember
stattfindet Susanne Seidel über Last
Minute Käufe in Schwerin
Besinnlichkeit an Heiligabend davon war
in Schwerin bis zum Geschäftsschluss
wenig zu merken viele Kunden waren noch
auf der Jagd nach Geschenken
und ein Notizbuch und was habe ich noch
gekauft
ja noch eine Teekanne alles so ein
bisschen für die Familie ja für die
Mutti muss ein Geschenk her und dann
machen wir das natürlich immer
rechtzeitig wie ich das gehört ja und
Schokolade ich habe gar nicht richtig
geguckt ich habe es einfach mitgenommen
ja eingekauft in Deutsch vergessen und
jetzt muss ich noch mal reinfahren so
voll ist das heute nicht daher geht das
doch ne gibt schlimmere Tage laut
Handelsverband Deutschland kaufen 2% der
Verbraucher ihre Geschenke erst am 23
und 24 Dezember
es gibt so anfallsarbeiter die sind
übrigens nicht nur beim
Weihnachtseinkauf so sondern auch auf
der Arbeit also die beenden Projekte
auch nur auf Druck hin und arbeiten dann
die Nächte durch Trinken Espresso und
schaffen es dann pünktlich für rund die
Hälfte der Händler lief laut
Handelsverband Deutschland das
Weihnachtsgeschäft eher durchwachsen
deswegen zählen für sie auch noch die
Kunden an Heiligabend die letzten die
noch so ganz vergessen haben oder doch
noch mitkriegen oh Gott meine Frau
hatten was für mich jetzt muss ich auch
noch mal schnell los oder auch wirklich
die die auf Montage sind die lange
unterwegs sind und wirklich erst am 24
nach Hause kommen Geschenke sollen
Freude machen und ob es heute oder schon
vor Wochen
das ist dem Beschenkten meist völlig
egal
das Wetter macht nicht so richtig Freude
viel Regen nur im Süden und Nordosten
freundlicher die Details hat gleich
Katja horneffer um viertel nach elf
bringt Sie Moritz Neuss auf den neuesten
nachrichtenstand hier übernimmt morgen
mit riserin und das gesamte 19 Uhr Team
sagt Danke und wünscht ihnen fröhliche
und friedliche Weihnachten auf bald
[Musik]
guten Abend in der Heiligen Nacht sinken
die Temperaturen auf 8 bis 0 Grad von
Südwesten zieht Regen auf und der
erreicht bis zum frühen Morgen etwa die
Mitte morgen regnet es erstmal wenig am
Nachmittag aber nimmt der Regen dann
hier von Westen wieder zu in
Süddeutschland wird es sehr freundlich
und auch im Nordosten werden sie
häufiger die Sonne zu Gesicht bekommen
die Höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen
zwischen 5 Grad an der Ostsee und 15
Grad am Oberrhein in den nächsten Tagen
geht es wechselhaft weiter der Dienstag
wird dann ruhiger fröhliche Weihnachten